i realize my girl's not cool she's just
not
[Laughter]
she's not a friendly human being i uh
i married a goddamn rattlesnake
this is my girl this is my girl man this
is what i'm dealing with yo
listen la's different than texas might
they just opened my son's school last
week he hasn't been school in a [ __ ]
year they just opened it last week first
day of kindergarten so i got him his
first day outfit looking all [ __ ] fly
dope kicks giant backpack backwards hat
looks just like me i'm walking up for
school i'm like dude it's about to be
lit as [ __ ]
all those little friends out front in
the first day outfits i'm like oh my god
you guys are cute as [ __ ] i need to
document this aot get tight there's a
bunch of you squeezing tight daddy's
gonna take a picture ready cheese on
three ready one two three
cheese they're all cheese i take it on
my phone i'm all hell yeah
i snap a pic i text it to my girl she
gets it she looks at she
goes crop out the uglies resend
what
excuse me
i said you're in a group chat to other
parents dumbass
[Applause]
savage all sabbath
[Music]
it gives me cold chills my [ __ ] is
super bad and she's thicker than oatmeal
[Music]
my